Speaker 1: Let's get to some Kerry Lake insanity.
Donald Trump recently said that we must terminate
parts of the Constitution to either reinstate
him. We're talking about 2020 here. Reinstate
him to the Oval Office or have a completely new
2020 election, even though it's almost 2023. This
was crazy and authoritarian and dystopian and
horrifying. And Kari Lake, who recently lost her
Arizona gubernatorial race but has a lawsuit and
is has prayers that she's using to try to get in
office. She says Trump was right to call for the
termination of parts of the Constitution. Yeah,
she's auditioning really hard to be
Donald Trump's VP. Their values write the
Constitution above all else. Except except here.
Speaker 4: A massive voter fraud of this type
and magnitude allows for the termination
of all rules, regulations and articles,
even those found in the Constitution. Our great
founders did not want and would not condone false
and fraudulent elections. I agree with him
on that. Whoa. Can you imagine our founding
fathers what they went through to help bring about
this great nation? Seeing what happened in 2020.
Speaker 1: Nothing happened. The
person who got the most votes, one.
Speaker 4: Really seeing what's happening now in
2022, just saying, okay, well, I guess it didn't
go our way and I guess they cheated. We know they
rigged the elections and they put in a bumbling
fool who doesn't even have the mental capacity to
run this country. Okay, just get over it. We'll
just let the loser take the White House. I don't
think that would happen. President Trump is saying
we are in unprecedented times and unprecedented
measures are necessary. That is what he is saying.
Speaker 1: Right. Carrie Lake agrees with
Trump. Terminate parts of the Constitution. Now,
as a reminder, Donald Trump's false statement on
truth social was quote and this was based on the
Twitter story. Okay, quote. So with the revelation
of massive and widespread fraud and deception,
in working closely with big tech companies,
the DNC and the Democrat Party. Do you throw
the presidential election results of 2020 out
and declare the rightful winner? Or do you have
a new election? A massive fraud of this type and
magnitude allows for the termination of all rules,
regulations and articles, even those found in the
Constitution. Our great founders did not want and
would not condone false and fraudulent elections.
I spoke earlier this week to you with peace and
love about the unfortunate reality that even
their most prized principles and values that they
claim to ascribe to almost like sacred texts,
the Constitution, free speech, not regulating
business says you all do. Okay. You know, they
abandoned them at the drop of a hat. At the
drop of a pin. If it's not convenient. And right
now, that sacred text to them, the constitution.
Is nothing. It's toilet paper that you flush ten
or 15 times, depending on the type of plumbing
that you have. How long is this going to be
accepted or even just looked the other way
out by a large portion of these right wingers, I
think for a long time, because they're all part
of it. They all don't really care about their
values if the values are no longer convenient.
And by the way, how long are people going to keep
interviewing Carrie Lake? Fox News often bills her
as former Arizona gubernatorial candidate.
Okay, she ran a race and she lost. For how
long does that keep getting you interviewed? I
don't know the answer. Just asking questions.